[Music]
hello good morning and welcome my name
is Jonathan and I'm an engineer at
Google and welcome to today's session
and we're going to talk about how to
build testable apps for Android so
through the history of time architecture
has continually evolved in style and
ambition to fit our expanding visions in
order to build these increasingly
complex architectures we've needed to
also innovate new tools and patterns and
methods to meet the demands of building
them and just like in the real world in
software - we've all had our own
evolutionary past we've seen this in
Android development - who remembers
building small applications in Eclipse
yeah and Newseum complexity of
applications grew so did the needed for
better tools and testing tools and now
today were building out quite complex
applications within Android studio and
last year there was jetpack which
included a lot of great libraries to
abstract some of the details allowing
those developers to focus on writing
great features but sometimes the
evolution hasn't always been easy and
choices developers have had to make
haven't always been so clear so how do
you answer questions such as how should
I architect my application or how do I
organize my codebase what library should
I choose and what tools should I pick
the choices that you make early on in
development have a long lasting impact
on the testability of your app and
thereby your development velocity and
your ability to add new features
sustainably well today we're going to
show you with some real-world examples
how to make the pragmatic decisions in
how you build your applications in order
to build a long-term testing strategy
and testing the key attribute to
consider is scope now scope means how
much of my applications in my test
covering and test could run in on just a
single method or they could span
multiple features multiple screens and
scope directly impacts to other
attributes of testing speed how fast
does your test run and some can take
from the order of milliseconds and
others all the way up to minutes or
maybe more and fidelity how close does
it to real-world scenarios does your
tests at case simulate an increasing
scope typically increases the fidelity
of your tests but it does so at the
expense of speed and vice versa and you
can't actually have a single test that
gives you the best of everything so the
question is when is good good enough
when do you really need perfect and how
do you achieve the right balance the
testing pyramid is used as a guide to
help you create that balance as you go
up the pyramid you improve on fidelity
by increasing the scope but remember
this comes at the price of speed focus
and scalability unit tests they've got
to be fast lightweight highly focused in
order that they can achieve high
scalability they're really easy to
define because most of the time we're
just testing a single method in a single
class within our application and this
means that they're going to give you
really high degree of focus to the
origin of a failure integration tests
are the next category of tests and here
we're trying to bring together several
units within our application and we're
interested in verifying their
collaboration making sure that when we
bring them together that they all behave
expected as a whole
and end-to-end tests they step through
key paths in our application after
uncovering multiple screens and features
and these are also really easy to define
because at this stage we know what
testing our whole application today
we're launching a new to do application
well it's not really an official Google
product but it is a real application
it's part of the refreshed Android
testing code lab that we're launching
today so you can go ahead check it out
build test work through all the examples
that you'll see right here in this
session today now we're going to work
through building this application
together and in doing so
along the way we'll discuss some of the
challenges and the choices that will be
faced building an application usually
starts by defining some key critical
user journeys and a critical user
journey is a step by step path that the
user takes through an application and
the idea is in order to meet a
predefined end goal the journey may span
multiple screens and decision points to
get to that end goal and they're often
sketched out by a series of mock-ups and
let's take a look at some that our UX
designers just sent us our first user
journey is that of creating a new task
users arrive on the home screen which
shows a list of tasks the first time
they get there is going to be empty
there's a floating action button that
they can click it takes them to the next
screen where they can enter details for
their tasks they can click Save and they
return back to the home screen and the
new task should show up our second user
journey is about checking our progress
so users can select an existing task
they can mark it is completed and then
they can go and view their progress on a
statistic screen that shows them just
how productive they are
now every project starts off small but
if careful attention isn't paid to
design architecture organization join
the growth of that codebase development
can quickly spiral out of control as
your application grows uncontrollably
without any thought your codebase can
quickly turn to a huge monolith a
spaghetti-like ball of incoherent
dependencies they're not only hard to
reason about but they're difficult to
test as well if individual units don't
follow key principles such as that of
high cohesion and low coupling they
become really difficult to test alone in
isolation and furthermore with a
monolithic codebase like this any time
you make a single change to your
application you have to rebuild
everything and these factors force the
majority of tests to end up being large
end-to-end tests how does this affect
our pyramid well with such resulting
chaos you can see that our pyramid is
now completely disproportional to how
we'd like it to look if we do try to
think about organization from when we
start out our first thought might be
following a layered architecture at this
stage in development it's the only
dimension that's visible to us and there
are also Android concepts that map
neatly to each layers so maybe this
makes sense and by structuring our code
this way we can slash dependencies
follow those principles of high cohesion
low coupling may be introduced
dependency injection and now we can see
that unit tests are possible but as our
application grows in complexity we start
to notice that it grows by the dimension
of features rather than architectural
layers so even if we did marginalize our
code this way a small change high up in
the tech stack is only gonna save a
couple of layers of modules of rebuilds
whereas something lower down still
causes a complete rebuild
the hold application furthermore the
layers themselves become monolithic and
so we still end up writing so many large
end-to-end tests now well the ability to
start writing unit tests is really good
projects are still left with a pyramid
that doesn't quietly look right and the
problem with this setup is that in order
to compensate for our fidelity gap in
unit tests were overcompensating
dramatically in end-to-end tests which
are slow and heavyweight there's nothing
here that's guiding us so far in order
to make a balance pyramid so a poorly
organized and architected codebase can
quickly lead to severe bottlenecks in
your development workflow by over
relying on these large end-to-end tests
we'll face with test Suites
that take far too long to run and the
lack of focus in them mean the bugs are
really hard to track down without
effective motorisation every change we
made to the app causes large swathes of
it to be rebuilt and all the tests must
be rerun these key points can cripple
your team's velocity but organizing your
code correctly has a big impact on
testability and development velocity so
we want to get it right from the get-go
we want to create a way that's going to
be scalable as we move forward and our
application grows over time so let's
think about how we may decompose our
project at the top we've got our
application and one of the key areas of
functionalities is managing tasks we
also have a progress module that has a
dependency on tasks and as we dive in we
notice that tasks is a really big
feature we can further decompose it with
add edit list view and organizing our
code this way allows our development to
scale as our application grows and new
features are added and we're also able
to scale in debt
of complexity to as features become more
complex we can continue breaking them
down adding more modules and this
approach to organization makes sense
since two components in the same domain
are much more related in function than
two components that might just happen to
be an activity we can implement this
kind of organization both through
language features such as packaging but
also through our build system like
Gradle modules or basil libraries we can
have two main orientated modules now to
the application and define clear API
boundaries to contractual eyes their
interactions so now we have a way to
shard our application which makes it
possible for the isolate the components
for more focused testing finally we can
see blueprints for integration tests and
of course all these module is going to
be decomposed and be unit testable and
we can still write a large end-to-end
tests furthermore this organization
allows us to scale as we add new
features the test scale along with them
you can use this guide as a starting
point and of course you can decompose
further or in different ways that make
sense for your application the key thing
here though is to remember to provide
natural guides and templates for
different categories of tests for your
application to build our to do
application we're going to be using some
of the architecture component libraries
from jetpack such as data binding view
model live data navigation and room
we're going to follow the model view
viewmodel pattern or mvvm to architect
our application this provides a really
clear separation of concerns and
jetpacks architecture component
libraries really fit in well neatly with
this when a start with a single activity
that uses the navigation component to
map the users throws through a series of
fragments each one managing its own
screen
each fragment has its own XML layout
this map directly to its own view model
use the datum using data binding our
architecture component
it'll also use live data to reflect
changes back up into the view and our
model a is going to be abstracted under
a repository that contains both a remote
data source and a local data source
that's backed by sequel Lite and using
room architecture component on Android
the user interface is updated on the UI
thread and so so long as the events that
we post there are nice short tasks are
you I say snappy and responsive in our
application however everything's not
gonna fit that criteria we use both a
local database and we make crests to a
remote REST API for dealing with task
data operations to both of these
components take a long time and if we
were to run these on the UI thread we
quickly see that our application becomes
slow or even unresponsive so of course
we need to make sure that these
long-running operations occur
asynchronously in the background somehow
so that we're not blocking our UI thread
from responding while waiting for these
tasks to complete in our application
we're going to make use of Kotlin zko
routines for asynchronous operations you
can think of co-routines
as lightweight threads and although
they've been stable for only a
relatively short amount of time the
community has adopted them very quickly
and they've become a clear trend in
android development a KO routine scope
keeps track of all the ko routines it
creates and if you cancel a scope it
thereby cancels all of the kuroh teens
that were created in that scope in our
application kuroh teens are launched
from the view model objects using a
special view model scope this is
particularly useful when our view model
gets destroyed because it automatically
cancels all of those existing child care
routines it's gonna save resources and
avoid potential memory leaks along the
way and for women is scope we can call
down to our tasks repository the
co-routine scope created our task
repository is concerned for parallel
decomposition of work when any child
co-routine in this scope fails the
entire scope fails and all of the
remaining co-routines are canceled this
function returns as soon as it's given
block and all of the child care routines
are both complete kuroh teens can
certainly make developing asynchronous
code a lot simpler so let's start by
implementing our first critical user
journey just to recap we start on the
home screen we click a floating action
button which takes us to the detail
screen here we enter text for a new task
save and we're back to the home screen
where we can see our newly created note
we're going to develop our application
using test-driven development and this
is a school of thought where we first
codify the specification of our
application in tests first of all and
only then do we write the production
code in order to satisfy that
specification we're also going to do all
this top-down starting from the
end-to-end test and in breaking this
down and decomposing further and further
until we finally reach the individual
units that are required to satisfy the
feature were building so let's start by
writing an end-to-end test it's going to
be failing first but we know that by the
time we make it pass our feature is
complete it's a good signal for the end
state let's review some key qualities of
end-to-end tests the main thing we're
looking for here is that we've got
confidence in the final application when
it's finished
therefore these kinds of tests should
run on a real or a virtual device
and to make sure that our code interacts
with the Android and Fire agreement as
expected our application should also
look as close to the final application
as possible that will go into ship and
we should test it in the very same way
that our users are going to interact
with it this means we're doing blackbox
testing and here we don't need to be
exhaustive with all the tests that's the
job of tests at other layers now let's
examine the scope of the code and see
what we know exercise in our test it
looks like for our our first test Coast
the add/edit task fragment screen and
the tasks fragment screen are what's
important so for this particular
end-to-end test we're just going to
discard ignore task details for the
moment we can start on the home screen
by using activity scenario to launch the
test activity class then we can click on
the floating action button which should
take us to the next screen and here we
can use espresso to enter text into the
detail screen and one more time with
espresso to click the button which is
send us back to the first screen and
here make a simple assertion to check
that the newly added task appears on the
home screen now we're not using any
special api's or any hooks or backdoors
this is known as blackbox testing and
interacting with the application this
way gives us the confidence it'll still
work if a real user were to step through
the flow in exactly the same way so now
we need to add some integration tests in
order to bridge the gap between those
large end-to-end tests that we've just
written and the smaller faster
exhaustive unit tests that we'll be
adding later here we're looking for
something that gives us a good clue that
all of the individual units
that were bringing together collaborate
as planned that's where the focus should
be here these tests should be relatively
scalable and providing enough coverage
at this level means we need to lean less
and less on those large heavyweight and
when tests here it's kind of less
important that we're using all real
components and it's okay to make to just
judicious use of testing api's but what
exactly kind of test should we be
writing at this level when we introduce
scope earlier in a session we define it
as the amount of real code that's
exercised by the test and in the
end-to-end test we've already seen that
scopes pretty large with integration
tests it's a little more nuanced luckily
our architecture and code organization
leads us straight to some good
candidates let's approach this by
decomposition if the previous end-to-end
tests just focused on the edited task
fragment screen and the tasks fragment
screen we already know that this next
integration test has got to be a smaller
scope than that and looking at our
architecture diagram I can already see
the first candidate let's start by
writing an integration tests for the
entire tech stack that supports the add
new task stream so we remove the task
list screen from the equation do you see
any other candidates here where we might
want to limit their scope of some of the
objects in the scope of your test might
have some undesirable characteristics
perhaps one of them is too slow maybe it
reads a large file at startup perhaps
another is a really heavyweight
dependency that takes a long time to
build perhaps it makes an arbitrary
network connections causing our test to
be flaky and some dependencies they just
can't be controlled in the way that we
need to simulate within our tests
in such cases you may want to consider
replacing that original dependency with
a test double test doubles our standings
for the real objects there are several
categories of test doubles each of them
range in fidelity dummies these are just
intended for stand-in for the real
behavior just to satisfy dependencies
then stubs which aim to offer one-off
specific behavior that allow you to
configure it for the needs of your test
either these could be hand rolled or
they could be provided by your mocking
libraries such as mojito or consider
fakes which aim to be a more accurate
yet lightweight substitute for the real
thing and you may be surprised to still
see real objects up here sometimes
though it makes sense to use real
objects in your tests if it avoids any
of those criteria that we consider
before and where it makes the test more
readable and robust over the alternative
value objects are just one example of
where you should always prefer using a
real object taking a closer look then
now some candidates where we might want
to start increasing removing the scope
we could drive our tests through task
activity but this is concerned with the
navigation between screens and we don't
need to test this at this level that's
more of an end-to-end test so instead
we're gonna reach for fragment scenario
and use this press o to test the UI
directly we're going to need to switch
in a test double for our navigation
controller however and we can use this
to verify that our navigation is working
as expected
tasks repository it presents a clear and
well-defined API to all the layers above
so it's good practice to make use of
this API from tests and to use that to
check to see if our tests had saved the
task correctly but look including a
remote data
which connects to an external server
that's gonna make our tests slow and
flaky so let's switch that out also for
a test double so first we're using
fragment scenario to launch our fragment
and we need to verify that our floating
action button sends us to the right
screen and the navigation controller
handles this kind of thing we don't
actually need to go to that new screen
for this kind of test we just need to
record that we went there so we can swap
out the navigation controller for a test
double there isn't actually a fake
version provided so in this case I think
it's perfectly acceptable just to ship
in a mock like this and now we can use
the espresso api's to enter some text in
the fields as we did before clicking the
floating action button to save the tasks
and for the final part of the test we
need to check two things first what the
tasks save correctly so we can do this
by obtaining the tasks service or the
tasks repository from the service
locator and we can use its api's to get
a list of the tasks that were saved and
then we can make sure it contains one
that was saved the match is the one we
tried to save through the UI the next
assertion is did we get back to the
right screen okay we can check with our
mark navigation controller to make sure
that the right navigation event was sent
that would have directed us to the right
screen
and we can be composed further and look
for other ways that we may want to limit
scope in order to create smaller and
smaller integration tests let's take
test repository for example it resent it
represents our model it's got a well
defined API that supports all the tasks
UI features as well as features in other
modules like the progress module and
it's also likely to contain large
amounts of complexity and business value
and includes a good deal of
collaborators and this makes it a great
candidate for covering with an
integration test so let's remove all of
the UI from the scope of this test now
we can proceed to directly test this
well-defined API of our task repository
and here we'll make similar choices when
it comes to fidelity telematic
principles and speed trade-offs just
like we did in the last test we'll keep
using a fake to stand in for the real
data source and as well as providing us
for repeatable tests a fake here allows
us to configure all kinds of test data
sets that we might want to wire up for
certain conditions testing in different
ways having a well-defined API the model
layer also allows us to do something
else that's really cool what if we take
our task repository and extract away an
interface now we can create a fake
version and by running the same test
against the fake that we run against our
production repository our fate becomes a
verified fake and what we're doing is
guaranteeing its behavior meets the same
specification as our real production
code and if we create separate modules
for both our api's and our fakes
other modules that we interact with will
seed faster build times and more
lightweight tests so here we have a fate
for our model layer that were confident
in and we can start to use it in other
tests coming back to the first
integration test we wrote for the
add/edit task cream
we could have equally written this
integration test with a fake task
repository
we trust our fake because it's a
verified fake and it's really fast - it
probably stores its data in an in-memory
hash map we can apply that same testing
blueprint across all of the other
modules in the tasks UI
these UI models modules are another
group of components whose integration
were really concerned with we want to be
sure that view models collaborate
correctly with our fragments is our data
binding wired up our all the possible
input validation cases handled correctly
and unit tests these verify the
operations of very small units of code
the scope of these kinds of tests is as
small as possible so the code can be
tested exco exhaustively and give very
fast and very specific feedback on
failures a large project is going to
have thousands of these so they should
run in milliseconds it's totally ok to
swap out production dependencies but
they should still be black box in nature
we want to be testing behavior not
implementation and the line between the
categories of tests here can get a
little blurry let's consider writing a
task for our tasks local datastore tests
local datastore takes a desk tasks Tao
as a dependency and in a real system
this is provided by the to do database a
class generated by room which is backed
by Android sequel ID and if we follow
the classic principles of unit testing
we can ask Marketo to provide as a mock
for our tasks now instead here in our
tests we can create that mock and then
pass it in as a dependency twelve tasks
local datastore we can create a new task
and then save it in the repository and
then finally we can validate the insert'
task coil call was in vote on our test
ow but wait
this test here already knows too much
about the implementation details of save
tasks how it's implemented if we were
ever gonna change that implementation
then the test is gonna need updating as
well even if the behavior was supposed
to remain the same this is what is known
as a change detector test and it's
burdensome maintenance can start to
quickly outgrow its usefulness effective
unit tests should really focus on
testing behavior instead but how should
we do that we can do that by ignoring
the internal implementation and focusing
on the API contracts instead take test
data source the contract states that
when I save a task through the save task
method I should still then be able to
retrieve that same task by looking it up
by ID so our test should acts to
exercise that contract rather than
concerning itself with implementation
details
so we'll exercise the save test method
on a local test data saw but we won't be
concerned with the fact that it calls
insert tasks on the Dow then we'll call
get tasks on a datastore again again
forgetting about the implementation and
one thing to bear in mind when writing
tests like this where the code under
test makes use of co-routines
is that we need to make these
asynchronous operations appear
synchronous so that our tests are going
to remain deterministic if we were to
get the if we were to call a get task
function and execute it and sometimes
the save task function hadn't completed
in time we'd end up with a flaky test
luckily doing so is rather
straightforward by asking our test to
run blocking one of the first tools you
learn to write tests that uses
co-routines
is the run blocking construct in the
context of run blocking the given
suspend function and all of the calls
children in the call hierarchy are
effectively going to block the main
thread until it finishes executing and
you're going to find this a really too
useful tool
when exercising code whose behavior
relies on co-routines and needs to be
highly deterministic so the test we
actually want to look right is gonna
look something like this we create a
task save it to the data source then we
ask the local data source to retrieve
that task back for us and finally we can
make an assertion that we got what we
expected
in fact Google and JetBrains have just
recently collaborated to just launch the
run blocking test co-routine builder and
this makes test for unko routines even
easier it's currently marked as an
experimental co-routines API so please
go and check it out and give us some
feedback and any bugs that you might
find so in order to write this test it's
important that our datastore maintain
state and it does this through its
dependency task Tao so the problem is
with using Marketo trying to maintain
state through these one-off stubbing
calls can get messy really fast so we
could instead implement our fake using
implement are tossed out using a fake
like we did earlier with repository but
we're gonna choose not to go down that
route for some good reasons firstly it
doesn't seem that the test our interface
is going to be part of our modules
public API and so no one else is going
to benefit from reusing that fake and
secondly right now I can't think of
another part of our code that would
benefit from that fake two and this is
one of those cases where it actually
makes sense to make use of the real
objects rather than putting in a fake in
this case room provides some really
useful testing infrastructure for us we
can ask room to build us an in memory to
do database and then we can use that to
obtain the tosto backed by that
in-memory database and provide it to our
local datastore
of course would clean it up after tests
but in all of the senses is the same as
the production database but is faster as
it doesn't write data to files on the
file system and therefore it also
provides better isolation through tests
so is this still a unit test or is it
now an integration test because we're
using real objects rather than just mugs
it's a good question and one many people
who will disagree on and it's true the
lines can become blurry at times but the
key takeaway here is that you shouldn't
ever be afraid of using real
dependencies in your tests where it
makes sense where they're more readable
more lightweight and robust so let's
just recap the times of tests that we
wrote today we added an end-to-end test
that covers a critical key user journey
through our application we decompose the
feature to add an integration test the
tests entire vertical slice through our
application from the UI down to the data
layer and we also added an integration
test that verifies our model which is
key because other modules are going to
be depending on our and finally we're
able to decompose and write smaller
groups of integration and unit tests
such as the ones for the UI or the local
data store marginalization of your
codebase with clearly defined intimate
rural contracts allow you to streamline
your project build create compile time
dependencies against small API modules
leading to faster build times on each
change an export testing infrastructure
such as lightweight verified fakes that
other modules can swap in and thereby
decomp decouple
their tests from your heavyweight
production dependencies so while you can
and should have end-to-end tests to give
you confidence in your app the vast
majority of tests should not be in this
category motorizing your app like this
allows you to push down many of those
large end to end tests to more focused
smaller
tests at the module level and each one
is decoupled from the next finally this
allows us to build a whirly
well-balanced pyramid and through this
success through this thoughtful
architecture there's a number of obvious
cutoff points that have surfaced
naturally within the pyramid you'll need
to identify the right spots for testing
in your own application what works for
one project might not work for another
so it's really important that whatever
you choose you document it clearly so
that all collaborators on your team are
on the same page in Android development
there's two kinds of tests local tests
that run on the VM level JVM they can be
just pure J unit tests or they can use
robolectric two pi to provide a
simulation of Android they're much
faster they're highly scalable but they
don't offer the same confidence that a
real device would on the other hand is
instrumentation tests that run on a real
or a virtual device while slower lacking
scalability they are true to the
behavior of real Android last year we
launched jetpack Android X test which
brought together a unified set of api's
that will work on both kinds of tests
and these api's allow us to focus on
writing Android tests without thinking
about the tools that were using
underneath or where the test is going to
be executed and at the heart of what we
relent releasing today is increased
stability improved interoperation with
Android studio better off device support
for espresso resources and the UI thread
control and a course of support for the
latest jetpack architecture components
while tests of all sizes can run on a
real or a virtual device these
improvements have made it possible to
run increasingly larger integration
tests faster on the local JVM all of the
integration tests that we've documented
today and in the code lab will run
equally well on both the local tree VM
on a real or a virtual device project
nitrogen is our vision for a unified
test execution platform it brings
together all these many disparate tools
and environments with nitrogen any test
that's written with the unified API
using Android X test can be run on any
of these execution platforms seamlessly
from Android studio or your continuous
build system you've got to up the option
to run any Android test and a variety of
these platforms such as virtual devices
cloud farms
simulated devices and while a team is
still working hard to bring this vision
to reality in the meantime we'll share a
little trick with you normally local
tests would be placed in the test source
route instrumentation tests go in the
Android test source route but to show
you what's possible with a unified API
in this code lab we're using a little
trick to create a shared test route
sauce root folder and here we can place
tests that written with the unified API
run on both device and off device and
how and where you decide to run them
really depends on your project's
philosophies or needs but here you can
start see the possibilities today we're
also launching an early access program
for nitrogen for tools integrators so if
you're a developer that maintains
monitoring profiling performance tools
you provide continuous integration
platforms you build real or device
services for developers you make IDs or
build farms we're looking to hear from
you and get your feedback on our early
access so please go ahead check out the
code in the code lab you can see the
great examples for project structure and
blueprints examples of the kinds of
tests you should be writing at different
level using the unified API and see just
what kind of tests are possible to run
on an off device which leads the way to
project nitrogen this is all available
online now and is right available right
here in the
whole other section for you to check out
[Music]